We are at Harvard University's Farmers'
Market which takes place every Tuesday at the corner of Kirkland and Oxford street from 12pm to 6pm.
My name is Caroline Manning,
I'm with the Harvard Farmers Market we're from
C&C Lobsters from down in Hull.
We are from Central Massachusetts and we're just
a little family owned operation
but here we are letting everybody into the joys of
maple.
We raise grass fed hormone free livestock
cows, sheep, pigs, turkeys, chickens,
quail, pheasant, goose, duck.
My stuff was all picked yesterday,
it's all
twelve or fifteen hours
out the field.
A lot of it I washed this morning and so
I think you can tell the difference looking at things
and tasting things
just that its fresh.
The guys that grow
our plants they start all the plants from
seed and they take care of them like they're their
children,
and this is what you get two years down the road.
Im cooking one day and I'm like what'll happen if I throw this this and this in the pot,
and so I came out with the Sweet and Sassy's its got the biggest
bite I prefer it in almonds but I prefer it in almonds but
I do it in cashews and pecans.
Something I just discovered this past weekend
was to cut one inch
slabs, and then drizzle it
with olive oil
and salt and throw it on the grill
and it gets black and crisp
on the outside and tender and sweet on the inside,
and the charred flavor does something about it
its delicious. You're buying them direct from
the fisherman,
which is helping the local fishermen,
and your getting a fresher product
because our lobsters are coming direct
out of their natural environment versus
refrigerated water and
tanks from the grocery store. It cuts out a middle man,
and its a really
inexpensive way to get
a business going ya know, you
just need a popup tent.
There's a diverse crowd here from
many countries,
so it's a great
opportunity to chat with people
about this natural product that comes right out of trees.
It's great because it has a ton of local farmers and vendors
from the area,
so there's a bunch of great stuff to choose from.